how Andrew takes conversion to Islam
appears to be corrupt in young men what
happened to what happened to today's men
are desperately asking how to be a man
I used to struggle reading the Quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app I never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
yes that's right I'm wearing a Cheval
candy my dear friend bought it for me
alhamdulillah I look good that's right
yeah that's right anyways Roman sisters
today's topic obviously as you guys know
Andrew Tate has been arrested I made a
video about that how Muslims should be
on that matter however very
interestingly let's read Telegraph yes
that's really terrible I think telegraph
was not aware that Andrew Tate became a
Muslim so before that him being a
non-muslim let's see what the heading
said of their newspaper so here's the
following today's men are desperately
asking how to be a man an Andrew Tate
provides an answer
that's true that's true yep that is that
is a correct statement that he tells men
to be men and act up and be responsible
and don't be couch potatoes or be little
kittens and he's telling men to reinvest
them re-embrace their masculinity and be
a real man a real man that provides for
his family you know and other other
things since he's uh come to Islam now
once the telegraph found out or they
found out that he accepted Islam they
said whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
who wrote that change it up a bit let's
spice it up because as you can see these
people are absolutely Hypocrites they
don't care about Justice do you really
believe the Western World cares about
Justice yeah like one individual said I
can't remember his name he said that the
West are strategically consistent not
morally they don't give a damn about
anything except if it benefits them even
to the newspapers so here we go what did
they say next they said how Andrew
Tate's conversion to Islam appears to be
corrupt in young men what happened to
what happened to today's men are
desperately asking how to be a man oh
why because yes he had specific views
that Islam didn't agree with but when he
accepted Islam and those joined together
alhamdulillah he gives the solution and
thousands I believe he is responsible
for thousands of people coming to Islam
thousands if not Millions right and
that's why we know where he is now yes
yeah until proven guilty so but what
happens when he's accepted Islam how
Andrew takes conversion to Islam appears
to be corrupt young men so it was Islam
that is corrupting young men and how is
it corrupting young men by telling them
to go to Traditional Values Andrew Tate
and men like him have held these
opinions which may be Crossing Lines yes
there was some stuff that was said but
if you take all those toxins out of some
of the views that they had Islam is has
been offering that from 1400 years ago
nothing new Andrew Tate has been just
saying and preaching that without Islam
but Islam has been preaching about a
long time ago and this is the double
standards of the telegraph the British
media which you might think there's so
many you know different media channels
and media radio stations no they own oh
they are mostly owned by a couple of
people at the top who are pulling the
buttons and making the moves brothers
and sisters subhanallah so there you go
shame on you the telegraph there you go
it just shows your hypocrisy and double
standards that if he's a Muslim
automatically and instantly he has
nothing good to offer the world
carry on because you cannot stop The
Message of Islam Allah says and they try
to put out the Noor of Allah the light
of Allah but Allah will perfect his
light even though the disbelievers hate
it
till the day we die may Allah make us
among those who preach Islam and Allah
has many of his servants who he will use
to propagate Islam and like the prophet
Muhammad said Islam will enter every
single household
before
goodbye